[Music]
he's been one of my favorite artists
since i was
like nine years old cannot confirm
or deny well it's not a no sean's new
interview with the uk's capital fm
is the latest hint that something's in
the works between the canadian
heartthrobs
after the two were spotted leaving
separately from the same la recording
studio in august
so a musical team up may still be
unconfirmed
but the two are definitely good butts
it's really cool
to have him as a a mentor in a lot of
ways just to kind of talk through stuff
with because there's not many people who
do this type of stuff meanwhile
congratulations are in order for kelly
rowland
who's expecting baby number two with
husband tim witherspoon
[Music]
the destiny's child alum unveils her
babylicious bond on the cover of women's
health
admitting she hesitated to share her
exciting news amid the turbulence of
2020.
the singer ultimately decided to make
the reveal because quote
you still want to remind people that
life is important and being able to have
a child
i'm knocking at 40's door in february
taking care of myself means a lot to me
kelly is also working hard to deliver a
new album her first
since 2013. she says i was thinking
oh my god my fans are going to be so
disappointed they wanted an album
first but they got a baby and i was like
i have to figure this out
so they get both still no word on when
the album might drop but the grammy
winner says she's due to give birth
before the end of the year
oh and there's one more grammy winner
with the baby on the way
[Music]
meghan trainor and hubby daryl sabara
tell the today shows hoda and jenna
they're expecting
during an appearance to promote megan's
upcoming christmas album and it finally
happened and we're so excited